what's going on guys this is rob and as
you guys know / my video schedule under
normal circumstances I would have a
video of my choosing up today would just
be something you know kind of cool like
I thought about doing renew your vows or
something like that and last night I was
trying to get it all sorted out and try
and decide what I wanted to do and then
at like 10pm last night I was going
through my email and and I saw that I
had received an email from geek & sundry
and they were like we're starting a show
and we'd like to have you want it you
know too I just helped launch it or
something like them and they were like
you know would you be interested in
joining and I was I was like yeah of
course and so um I'm flying out to
burbank california here in about three
hours and yeah it's like a last-minute
flight and it's like I want to be there
until the 12 so I mean I don't have
those videos finished um so I guess I
don't really have anything to upload but
for those of you guys who are following
me on Twitter um who on like periscope
and that kind of stuff feel free to send
me like you know I guess I'll be
periscoping and so on you know kind of
talking to you guys here and there and I
think it'll be pretty cool you know to
hang out and kind of talk about it all
and via the hotel and that kind of stuff
but I don't know if I'll be able to
periscope when I'm actually there you
know assuming that I'm you know
recording the show and so on but um I'm
excited like I'm really excited you know
to be part of a show that geek & sundry
is going to be launching so I don't
think I've geek & sundry is but they're
like this big hub for pop culture and
stuff like that it's really cool so I
mean to be issued like an invitation
like to be asked if I want to be out
there is really really exciting and so
um I'll be back on Saturday at around
five o'clock or so after I get back like
I'm gonna immediately get back to work
again and so um hopefully on Sunday like
i'll have that man in game up and and
we'll be able to kind of get to anyone
from there but for yeah but for right
now like it's like i didn't i didn't
expect this like it was they literally
sent an email at 10pm yesterday and I
was like I mean
I can't miss out on a chance to do
something like this and I've kind of
been debating for the last few hours you
know since around 7am you know should I
should I just stay here and make videos
or should I you know get you know take
just take a chance like go out there and
give it a shot and so I'm gonna go out
there and give it a shot and hopefully
it won't be too detrimental to my
channel hopefully you guys want all just
bail out like with a screw Rob like I'm
never gonna watch this channel again and
just kind of take off from there but um
yeah like it's it's it's crazy like it's
it's kind of nuts but yeah it's it's
wild how far this whole YouTube thing
has come like it's you know it's it's
kind of nuts um yeah I'm like making
videos like this like I feel like I
haven't made a video like this for a
while and and I kind of mess you know
doing these occasional vlogs you know
most people don't care about it most
people just want chemical content that's
fun you know I don't care about it but
you know it's it's it's I like the idea
of talking directly to you guys you know
and um you know this this YouTube thing
is is crazy like like it's had its ups
and downs it had his bumps and its lumps
you know I'm like when I started this
I'll be honest with you guys when I
started this whole YouTube thing that
was flying by the seat of my pants I
mean it was true was good when it was
nuts you know and trying to get
everything organized then like last like
last winter came around that's really
where things got super shaky because it
was trying to like you know go into
YouTube full time there are things you
can do and things he can't do and it was
trying to get those things sorted out
trying to get them ironed out and trying
to you know trying to figure out how
YouTube works and there were some people
who were just like screw you rod like
I'm never like I'm never watching your
content again and there were some that
that's stuck through it all for those of
you guys are stuck through it all I
appreciate it like a you guys have no
idea how much I appreciate you and for
all the new people who were showing up
you know you guys are you guys are
amazing too hopefully you stay
but um you know I like the idea of
having a schedule now in terms of wind
stuff gets uploaded you know and for
those of you guys who own who aren't
familiar who aren't who are little like
who don't know about the whole video
schedule thing that I have because I
don't think I'm officially announced it
you'll find it down in the description
but basically like you'll actually pull
it out to make sure that I'm right here
I rely on like spreadsheets for
everything um so sunday is like it like
new 52 videos so so that's like Batman
getting us
come upon Batman and in games where that
stops and so from there like we'll be
caught up on Batman and then like monday
is a marvel video of some comment and
then you know of course tuesday's top
five and then wednesday is another DC
video Thursday is a video for me which
is usually probably gonna be like a
mortal video or something like that and
then Friday's indie comics and saturday
is anime and of course the anime thing
is really kind of tentative that's
really more of an experiment on my
behalf to see how I feel about it you
know it may stay it may not you know it
may be that that you know after a while
I'm just kind of like that it was fun
but you know we're gonna try something
else instead and that's cool and that's
that's the basis of YouTube try new
things seeing how they work out and you
know if you know if it's cool and
sticking with it and if not then going
with something else you know in terms of
anime like I love dragon ball z I've
always loved dragon ball z you know I'm
in the mindset now where I just kind of
produce videos that I really enjoy a
kind of figure doesn't make any sense i
have a youtube channel if you don't if
you don't like the videos that you make
its kind of so it's kind of
self-defeating but um but yeah so for
everybody this here you know all the new
folks and all the ones who have stuck
through all the chaos of me trying to
get my channel sorted out i do want to
say thank you you know you guys are you
guys are awesome and and yeah so i guess
i'll be periscoping you know sometime in
the next little while about you know
it's like a nine and a half hour flight
getting out there like I travel to North
Carolina then to Dallas and then to Los
Angeles search me on why but apparently
that's how it is and yeah so I guess um
I'll be back here in the captain's chair
on Saturday and I will catch you guys on
her please